- Grandma Millie is shrinking.
Her height decreases by a
quarter centimeter each year.
She want to predict the
total change in her height
over the next three years.
Which of the following equations
matches the situation above?
Her height is decreasing.
We can view that as either
changing her height each year
is a negative fourth of a centimeter.
That's going to happen for three years.
We multiply negative
one-fourth times three.
Which is exactly what's
happening in this first choice
right over here.
Her height is decreasing by a
quarter centimeter each year,
that's this part right over here.
She's doing this for three years.
After three years,
her change in height would
be negative three-fourth
of a centimeter.
You just multiply this out,
which means that she lost
three-fourths of a centimeter.
The second choice would evaluate,
if you multiply positive
one-fourth times negative three,
you still get negative three-fourths,
but this doesn't seem
to follow as naturally
from this statement up here.
We're decreasing by a fourth.
I like putting the negative
in front of the fourth,
and then we're going in
forward in time by three years.
It feels weird to put a
negative on the three.
We're not backwards in time here.
Even though this expression
evaluates to the same
things as this first one,
the first one seems to better match
what this statement is describing.
I wouldn't pick none of the above
just because I found one that I like,
that I think that describes
the equation that matches
the situation above.
Let's do another one of these.
A zombie lost three limbs
each day for four days.
He's going to lose 12
limbs, three times four.
It's not a human zombie.
It's an alien zombie that has
at least 12 limbs to lose.
The following equation
describes this situation.
The zombie lost three limbs each day.
Lost three limbs.
A negative three could represent,
hey I'm losing three limbs.
The negative is going ...
my number of limbs is going down by three.
This is negative three.
It's dong that for four days.
For four days.
We have negative 12,
which is the total number of
limbs that our zombie loses.
What does negative 12 tell us?
Well, I just said it.
The zombie lost a total of 12
limbs over this time period.
That looks right.
Now, let's see what are these other one.
The zombie has negative 12 limbs.
Well, no.
To have negative 12 ...
I don't even know a
negative limb would be.
We don't know how many limbs
the zombie started with.
The zombie, I don't know,
it might be some type of
centipede zombie or something.
It might have had a hundred limbs,
and if it lost 12 of them,
it would now have 88 limbs.
The zombie might have had 12 limbs,
and now it has a zero limbs.
In fact, I don't even know
how you get to negative limbs.
I don't think this makes sense.
I'm not going to pick none of the above,
because I agree with this first choice.
Let's do one more of these.
All right, a certain reality TV show
lost, so we're losing,
so a negative might be a nice
way to represent the lost,
lost a total of 9,000 viewers over
the past three months.
Over three months.
It lost the same number
of viewers each month.
The following equation
describes the situation.
It lost a total of 9,000 viewers,
and it did it over three months.
What they're figuring out here is,
what was the change in viewership.
What was the change in
viewership per month?
It tells us ...
the negative 3,000 tells us
that they lost on average ...
it actually tells us they
lost the same number.
This is actually ...
it's the same number every month.
They actually lost 3,000
viewers every month.
Let's see which of these
choices match up to that.
There are 3,000 fewer
people watching the show
compared to three months ago.
No, they lost 3,000 every month.
That's what this is telling us.
Every month for three months.
There's a same number each month.
They lost 3,000 every
month for three months
for a total of 9,000.
This isn't right.
The total change in the number of people
watching the show is negative 3,000.
Over a month that would be true,
but the total change was 9,000,
or a negative 9,00 I guess I could say.
They lost 9,000.
I would say none of the above.
Well, the negative 3,000 tells us
that there was a choice that said,
each month they lost 3,000 viewers.
That's the choice that I would pick.
I would say none of the above.